intervenir le futur aéroport
international de notre dame des landes à
quelques 30 kilomètres au nord de nantes
pourrait ouvrir dans quelques années
peut-être dans 15 ans c'est ce qui
étudie en effet en ce moment le conseil
général de loire atlantique
si tout va bien début du chantier notre
dame des landes dans huit ans aussi
extraordinaire que cela puisse paraître
c'est peut-être ici derrière moi sur ses
terres de notre dame des landes que se
poseront en l'an 2007 les premiers
avions gros porteurs à vocation de
desserte à la fois inter régional pour
tout le grand ouest mais aussi c'est
important internationale ça fait belle
lurette qu'il est question de ce projet
porté à bout de bras notamment par les
présidents des conseils généraux de
loire-atlantique et d'ille-et-vilaine
charles-henri de cossé brissac et pierre
méhaignerie cependant dès 1975 on
assistait à une mobilisation du monde
rural riverains de notre dame des landes
contre ce projet d'aménagement de
plateforme aéroportuaire sur quelques
milles hectares aujourd'hui qu'en est il
à l'heure qu'il est bon aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que tout le monde a plus ou
moins laissé tomber quoi enfin dans les
idées ou à disons ça changeait quoi on
s'est bien rendu compte qu'on peut pas
aller contre le progrès c'est dommage
pour la qualité de l'environnement de
qualité de vie en général on va vers des
nuisances sonores
les premières conclusions du comité
d'étude sont tombés elle laisse
apparaître qu'on pourrait évoluer à
terme vers une saturation de trafic sur
l'aéroport de nantes-atlantique ex
château bourgon d'où la nécessité de
prévoir avec une décennie davance la
réalisation d'un nouvel aéroport et
d'éviter ainsi des investissements
doubles emplois sur celui de
nantes-atlantique
si une décision définitive été prise en
1997 le début des travaux interviendrait
alors en l'an 2000 reste cependant
encore à connaître la position d'un
acteur essentiel du dossier l'état